hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play white
knight okay you might be wondering hey
this isn't where we left off that's
because I spent basically an entire
episode trying to get from where this is
where we started from here trying to
solve this puzzle in here and I swear
this one has been a son of a [ __ ] to
solve because I just I seriously I
cannot seem to get it but basically the
idea is there is a key or something in
here
the tub the water in the tub is too hot
for me to get to it and there are these
pipes that run along the wall that you
can see here and the pipes lead all the
way around but loop around there's a big
hole in the ceiling where that pipe runs
and it loops around and they're these
itty-bitty little valves you you need to
open what what has happened is over here
oh is that okay nevermind what happened
over here is I ran into a little bit of
a problem because this doesn't seem to
be any water flowing anywhere because I
this this valve popped off of this one
and then they can't seem to get it to
run across the top here I mean I want to
figure out how to do that but now these
valves don't seem to want to move for
some reason so I might be doubly screwed
I have no idea this doesn't move this
should move and if I do this it'll start
spewing out water here the objective is
to get the water all the way over to the
other side and I honestly can't seem to
be able to do that so I locked that one
down that one's open this one should
spit out water if it was open but it's
not for some reason again I'm not
exactly sure oh there it is okay that's
spitting out water now ergo this one for
some reason doesn't want to move any
more and now that one's broken too it's
just you know it's a confusing situation
now and I have I have been like have my
flashlight out the entire time because I
was trying to record AB scrap an entire
episode because okay water is flowing
out there as well so I have water here
here and here which means that I got
nothing
because now the valve that leads up top
seems to be stuck unless somehow this is
gonna decide to work which it might you
know it might holy crap it is what uh
hell I swear I was like messing with
this for ten hours before apparently I
didn't turn it all the way off and then
all the way back on but okay this is
turn this all the way off and then turn
it all the way back on and maybe turn
this one all the way off and all the way
back on nope okay what about this one
what about this in right here turn this
oh oh turn it on ah here we go and now
in all the way on and then if I turn
this one all the way off and then I'm
like you're doing oh do i whine oh balls
and then turn this one oh wait do this
one again all the way off oh yeah you
like my wheel turning skill aw okay I'm
assuming that means water's flowing and
then turn this one oh my god it might
actually be it all the way off and all
the way on ha yeah
now going to crazy Oh what that why did
its light at the bottom I didn't make
any sense at all okay whatever either
way I got it I got it
finally I have it that took much longer
than you guys realize oh and that was a
note from this stool I guess I could go
back and read it regression is that it
one patient told one a patient dear to
me told me that all people live relying
on their knowledge and perception and
are thus bound to them those boundaries
are what they tend to accept as reality
however knowledge and perception are
both ambiguous so reality could be
nothing more than an illusion people
live trapped in their limited perception
do you see what is reality then I ask
doesn't matter what I'd say she answered
she was right it wouldn't matter what
could I prove what I kept what could I
do to prove that she was right back then
since then there is a question
prepossess my mind what if someone loses
all his memories what would what would
he believe what would be reality for him
and most importantly could we insert new
memories to create a unexist
reality for him although I'm respected
throughout my country now I couldn't
save her back then I still have a lot to
learn which leads me to think that the
main care to this thing is like a test
subject for Patrick pars Patrick pars
experimentation which would explain a
lot so pegleg yeah into the sewers which
is always gonna be a fun time in amnesia
in any horror game really as sewers are
the epitome of level design and
creativity
[Music]
why no I don't believe you dot dot dot
I'm gonna move oh no I'm moving screw
you I'm running huh what's going on
Bob all Holloway crap holy crap look at
that worm what the hell whoa my sanity
is suddenly dangerously low what what
the hell is that oh it's a giant one big
euphemism if you know what I mean okay
am i up now okay well I guess the giant
worm thingy is gone I uh I'm not
listening to a word this lady says cuz I
do not trust her I think they're all
experimenting on me it's kind of loud in
here isn't it
generate what oh hey hey oh these were
gonna open anyway whoops not bad I might
need to break this again my gigantic
moose goals
whoops I missed boom flooby-doo SHhhh
nothing happens mmm nothing happens
oh well I know nothing happens there's
probably bad news and I'm down here in
the dark isn't it I don't have enough
batteries to uh do you finish out what I
got going on here it's really dark down
there it's uh like pretty dark down here
don't you think and quiet quiet and dark
are not good combinations if you know
what I mean you know what I mean yeah
stinky kooky poopoo sewer water I don't
want that to touch my nice new kicks oh
this looks nice hmm kind of a classroom
deal going on here
batteries yes need need need need need
need batteries in this complete renewal
it's crucial that the generator must be
replaced first however dr. s didn't
listen to me and now all hospital
suffers from local electrical shutdowns
not my mistake like previous power
failure that generator is very old and
it's sometimes may go off without reason
last week it went off twice if it goes
off again it might be possible
impossible to fix it that's not good
news in case of an emergency
what was that that in my room I remember
my closet being open make sure you have
a filled gasoline can fill the container
next to the generator with gasoline to
give a starting force pull the switch
next to the container switches old too
so you might need to pull it twice
whatever you
that squishy squish sounds like
footsteps really disconcerting really
disconcerting
keep-keep bigger than something behind
me okay how do I get up I need a box to
jump on yeah probably
come here boxy come here boxy bare boxy
the queen of be you know boxy has a
youtube channel now I discovered that
recently yeah she doesn't make many
videos but you know she actually has one
unlike oag she has not capitalized on
her internet fame as well as she could
this does not look good here gurney
boxes gurney boxes gurney oh she gurney
door it's too heavy and I can't open
that I need to start to generator okay
so I need to get a gasoline can and fill
it up I've got a key that can probably
unlock one of the doors
well what's down here hello something
new
oh I can't pick up that axe do not
forget to wash your hands after you kill
someone oh it's stuck Oh get out of here
get out of here
ha ha I don't trust that at all I don't
like that even a little bit that is
exceptionally unlike miss good I'm gonna
run out of batteries geez hop hop to me
box you're coming with me
pervert oh come on come here back up
there we go alright there was a couple
doors down here that I can probably open
now whoop whoop yeah like a mouse Oh
what oh come on
yeah there we go now go down this dark
hallway again just to make me run out of
energy drink energy energy [ __ ] get
[ __ ] up anyone anyone wants that ok
here we go
what's in here barrels of flammable
fluids flailing flamboyantly into the
flatulent flatulent feet what done
there's nothing here
I don't see a gas can boxes kind of got
knocked over on their own but don't know
what that was all about her oh this can
push this really easily ok I don't see
anything there's nothing here there's no
gas cans uh-uh
I can't move these I can Pandi boom
everything explodes and I'm about to run
out of batteries this not a good
situation to be in
I only have the one key and that's the
only door to open and that door won't
move maybe was a gas can in this room
that I didn't see ah
balls I can't even reach those
generators what what the hell is going
on what do I miss what did I miss
oh there's the gas can oh hello
batteries cool awesome thank you so much
I needed those uh-huh
ok so I can see I think can I stack up
no I can't go over there um can I go
around no doesn't look like it how can I
get in there I see the door but the door
is it won't move I'll get the door to
open it maybe throw up oxide it charged
out your gloop landmark pyre why don't
you carry through we got one I think I
will markiplier could you guys whip
personalities or LTG that blade would be
boring ok so it just won't move oh I
guess I was hurt a little bit the lock
is broken
ok come here box I have an idea that's
probably gonna lead to my death just
like most of my ideas huh ha ha
invisible wall alright so what's the
what's the deal here once the UM what am
I supposed to do yeah what am I supposed
to do here yeah how about that how about
that was there a key that I missed or is
there really just you know something
that I'm not getting here
maybe there's a way to get these things
to detonate if I could get these to
explode wait what's that in a whole new
ball and what is that no okay thought I
might have been a hole in wall I was
very wrong
get those to explode by throwing a box
at it her nope
fall down kaboom nope nope I must not be
on the right track mmm looking up don't
see anything generator won't turn on
without gasoline what did the notes say
besides just the instructions throw the
container next his generator with
gasoline to give it a starting force
pull the switch if the switch is old oh
so you know I mean it might need to pull
it twice okay so generally this door is
saying though that the lock is broken
not just it's you know it's not gonna
work it's actually completely broken so
ergo that door is not intended open so
the answer must not be the door itself I
can see it here there must be something
that I can do for this
there's leaky oil there that I might be
a little light if I had them a lighter
or something oil cans knocked over there
looks to be like a hammer in there it
doesn't help me out here so I seem to be
stuck at the moment can't seem to figure
it out okay so to not waste you know
batteries and whatnot I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna cut the episode here because
um in a minute I'm not gonna finish it
so if you guys know what I need to do
please let me know in the comments below
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]
my